[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP nous sommes
ensemble pendant 1 heure on va parler
cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologie et aussi un peu politique et
cette semaine nous recevons Emmanuel
Jarry bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et avec moi pour
présenter cette émission Jean-Pierre
Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigit bonjour Emmanuel Jarry bonjour
Jean-Pierre alors vous êtes critique
gastronomique version 2.0 on peut vous
suivre depuis 2016 sur votre chaîne
Youtube c'est meilleur quand c'est bon
là on vous voit généralement attabler
dans un petit restaurant un bistro un
commerce de bouche c'est pas du 4
étoiles c'est simple c'est authentique
vous commentez les plats vous vous tapez
la discute avec le chef c'est plus
qu'une critique c'est une tranche de vie
alors ce qu' concept vous l'avez décliné
en livre et en trimestriel un magazine
qui s'appelle aussi c'est meilleur quand
c'est bon cette aventure vous la lancé
avec votre mari Mathieu pensard qui vous
filme mais dont on ne connaît que la
voix alors ça décolle vraiment en 2019
avec une vidéo à 40 million de vues chez
AW carton assuré on vous arrête dans la
rue vous la femme de presse écrite qui a
étudié 10 ans l'ethnologie de la cuisine
et c'est là que ça se complique quand
vous nous avez donné votre menu on a été
obligé avec Jean-Pierre d'ouvrir une
encyclopédie oui une soupe oubliée
inédite au drôle de nom une soupe châée
on vous en dira plus tout à l'heure et
on dessert une mousse au chocolat dans
le dessous des plats les influenceurs
foot font la pluie et le BE temps sur la
gastronomie faut-il suivre leur avis les
précisions de Clément Perou dans les
pieds dans le plat de cuisse de
grenouille à la persiane attention le
reportage à venir pourrait bien vous en
dégoûter allez on passe à table tout de
suite cuisine et
confidence
d'abord Emmanuel Jarry pour vous dire
qu'en recevant une critique
gastronomique dont le slogan est c'est
meilleur quand c'est bon on était plutôt
rassuré d'avance avec Brigitte sur votre
choix culinaire du jour bon c'est déjà
meilleur que quelconque ou que médiocre
notre seul doute se résumer à cette
question en Berli ficoté ce sera
seulement bon ou alors meilleur que bon
bon bref pour dénicher des indices je me
suis plongé d'abord dans votre livre
mais c'est le numéro 3 de votre revue
datée de décembre 2023 qui m'a permis
d'y voir plus clair avec ces recette
d'hiver oubli que vous avez exhumé comme
la pintate farci marron la Pella des
aravies les ouillettes de Lang vous
connaissiez les ouillettes de langue
Brigitte ce sont des chaussons farcis au
canard confit mais vous avez souhaité
nous réchauffer nos corps et nos âmes
avec une bonne soupe de montagne au
fromage la soupe châée adjectif pour le
moins curieux qui désigne d'ordinaire
plutôt un chapon qu'une soupe antiaspi
confectionné à partir de rest que
vous-même de votre propre aveu vous
n'avez jamais goûté mais qui vous fait
terriblement envie voilà donc l'occasion
qui fait le Laron en espérant que vous
allez nous dire comme une enfant
gourmande c'est beaucoup meilleur euh
oui ça c'est important pour moi c'est
ces recettes là pourquoi je les ai pas
goûté parce que justement c'est des
recettes qu'on ne connaît pas mais moi
la première pour cette revue dont vous
avez parlé je travaille avec des
stylistes culinaires avec des
photographes et je leur ai demandé
justement de faire ce travail alors moi
je vais chercher j'ai toute une
collection de livres de cuisine depuis
20 ans que je m'intéresse à ça et et
elle aussi et donc on a Exumé comme ça
des des recettes mon idée c'est pas de
comme je disais dans la revue numéro 2
il y avait une recette je l'ai déjà dit
qui m'a un peu traumatisé c'était une
quiche au saumon et au
poireau ban c'est un peu banal et j'ai
dit surtout on a pas besoin on a pas
besoin non mais c'est c'est c'est une
super recette mais on a pas besoin de
ces meilleurs quand c'est bon en fait
pour pour donner C mais là sont des
recettes régionales qui sont oubliées ou
on consomme quand même très localement
parce que moi je les connaissais pas
j'avoue non mais voyez c'est possible
moi je pense que dans certaines familles
on les fait encore mais pour avoir quand
même beaucoup parcouru la France et
filmeré des restaurants ou pour faire
des reportages avant pour la presse
écrite je n'ai jamais mangé dans des
restaurants des soup châré voilà c'est
ça et moi je trouve qu'il y a une
uniformisation des goûts en France du
fait de la restauration notamment parce
que les chefs cuisinent toujours les
mêmes choses et donc je me suis dit àe
mer quand c'est bon on va bah faire ce
que j'aime aller retrouver des recettes
qu'on ne fait plus mais qui parle d'une
région en fait voilà c'est ça c'est un
peu comme les vieux légumes qu'on exhume
et qu'on remet comme ça en C oui et non
parce que les vieux légumes c'est des
produits moi ce que je déplore parce que
souvent quand j'ai fait mes reportages
et je dis vous faites bien une cuisine
locale on me dit oui oui je je j'achète
chez le marécher à côté et pour moi une
cuisine locale c'est pas parce qu'on
achète les produits à 5 km ça va presque
ça ça tombe sous le sens en fait
d'acheter local aujourd'hui ce qui est
important une cuisine locale c'est de de
de cuisiner en Enjou à Marseille
Marseillais en Enjou une cuisine en
Juine et en Alsace cuisine alsacienne
alors il se trouve que les Marseillais
ils ont encore une culture culinaire
qu'ils ont su préserver le le
Pays-Basque aussi il y a plein de
régions comme ça à l'Alsace beaucoup
beauoup Rion bien sûr oui mais alors
jeussite toujours l'enjou les pauvres
enjins il doit se dire mais à chaque
fois qu'elle parle de nous mais parce
que je fait un reportage en Enjou
impossible de trouver une recette en
jevine donc je suis allée les chercher
et donc j'ai demandé avec les personnes
parce qu'on est une vingtaine à
travailler pour cette revue notamment
les six culinaires j'ai dit trouvez-moi
des recettes que même moi je ne connais
pas donc la soupe châée je ne l'avais
jamais goûté goû alors goûtezla
dites-nous dites-nous effectivement si
vous la trouvez si vous la trouvez bonne
al je P TR choses à savoir oui parce que
comme on la connait pas pour une fois
cette rubrique peut servir à quelque
chose la littérature culinaire et peu
prolix sur l'histoire de cette soupe
châtrée ce qui semble sûr c'est que
cette recette est restée confinée à un
petit territoire autour du village de
Morillon près de SW Moens ceux qui font
du ski le connaissent à moin qui
revendique d'ailleurs Morillon la
paternité de cette soupe pour la
confectionner il faut superposer une
couche de pain sec une couche de fromage
une couche de pain sec une couche de
fromage vous remplissez votre soupère et
à la fin fin vous arrosez le tout avec
une soupe aux oignons mais attention une
soupe aux oignons filtré c'est-à-dire
sans les oignons et vous faites ça cuire
au four plus d'une heure à 180° voilà la
soupe va ainsi gratiner et le fromage
qu'on mange là va durcir voilà pourquoi
il faut la châer Jonathan qui s'est
occupé de ça tout à l'heure la découper
avec un couteau il faut la châer
l'émasculer j'allais dire les puristes
des SIME la savoure d'ailleurs avec une
fourchette et autant dire qu'après une
soupe châée c'est bien l'appétit qui
coupé alors c'est une soupe d'hiver mais
on la mange aussi le 21 août ah d'accord
on la mange l'été aussi ou oui pour la
saint-christop mais ça ça n'a rien d'une
soupe he on est d'accord non parce que
parce que oui je vous dis des puristes
la mangent à la fourchette parce qu'en
fait le pain a absorbé tout le jus de la
soupe qui avait été versé dessus alors
est-ce que là elle est un peu sec sèche
j'en sais rien mais en tous les cas
c'est bon et c'est gourmand et c'est
très c'est bon non moi j'aime beaucoup
parce qu'il y a du fromage fondu du pain
et c'est vraiment voilà c'est cette
cuisine que j'aime beaucoup un peu
paysane dans laquelle on utilise les
restes et on utilise parce qu'on avait
là on voit bien que c'est une recette
ancienne parce que on imaginait qu'il
restait des restes de croûte à un moment
donné de l'année il nous reste un peu de
pain il est dur comme du béton donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait bah on le mouille
avec un peu d'eau on met des oignons
parce que ça parfume économique on met
du fromage voilà c'est ça et et ben en
fait après une journée de ski je pense
que on est content de manger
ça mais c'est pour ça voyez que je
trouve ça dommage l'uniformisation des
goûts et de de se dire que aujourd'hui
on va trouver je sais pas du foie gras
voilà le foie gras c'est le truc qu'on
trouve partout la souris d'agneau parce
que si vous êtes sur la Côte d'Azur vous
avez pas du tout envie de manger ça h et
vous donc c'est les recettes elles ont
pas été inventées pour rien la cuisine a
son histoire et tout alors désolé pour
les restaurateurs qui nous écoutent tout
le monde ne fait pas ça mais ceux qui
qui nous proposent toujours la même
chose du foie gras de la souris d'agneau
de je sais plus bon là j'ai enfin parter
en guerre contre plein de petits resto
contre tous les bistr contre non parce
que c'est la cuisine bistro c'est un peu
toujours la même bah surtout la
bistronomie en fait moi je pars en
guerre contre la bistronomie mais je dis
il en faut aussi parce que la
bistronomie ça a permis d'apporter la
haute cuisine à un prix moins cher parce
qu'il y a pas tout le service de la
haute gastronomie que j'aime aussi
beaucoup tout le rituel du service mais
bon ça a permis d'apporter au plus grand
nombre voilà exactement mais je il faut
pas en fait on parle toujours du fastf
pour l'uniformisation des goûts et je je
le dis moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas que
les fastf il y a aussi les chefs qui à
un moment donné ont voulu tous faire la
même chose parce qu'il y a des modes et
que la mode en cuisine c'est vraiment
appauvrir la cuisine donc vous le
demandez quoi plus de d'être créatif bah
oui d'aller rechercher si vous êtes dans
une région alors vous pouvez avoir envie
d'être créatif c'est super mais tout le
monde n'a pas ne peut pas être un chef
créatif tout le monde donc déjà aller
chercher ce que les les siècles nous ont
laissé c'est bien aussi mais et cultiver
les produits du terroir oui bah ça ça me
paraî évident ou ouais ça c'est
complètement absurde d'aller chercher
des produit dans le Nord si on habite à
Menton enfin voilà on trouve un peu dur
avec la bistronomie parce qu'on en a
souvent parlé sur ce plateau vous dites
que c'est uniforme au contraire on
reproche aussi la bistronomie de faire
d'être trop inventive créative pour être
créative avec des slash en choix
pampelumousse skiwi burata et il y a eu
plein de créations après elle s'est pas
uniformisé je trouve que tu avis dans
des la bistronomie elle elle procure et
elle elle propose un éventail de de
plats et de recettes ben je trouve qu'en
fait les tout le monde n'a pas la
capacité d'être un chef créatif ça je le
pense et la la créativité des grands
chefs il y en a vraiment des très grands
chefs français hein c'est ce qui fait
aussi notre grande cuisine mais tout le
monde ne peut pas vous savez il y a les
il y a l'artisanat dans la peinture et
puis il y a les grands maîtres de la
peinture donc voilà je pense qu'en
cuisine c'est pareil et donc donc la
bistronomie les slash pour moi c'est pas
de la création c'est l'originalité pour
être original mais je je résume toujours
la
bistronomie les les navel non les BET
Kodia coupé à la mandeline avec l'INE de
noisette voilà pour moi c'est ça la la
mauvaise bistronomie par voilà c'est ça
parce qu'en même temps il y a des chefs
comme le Matthieu Garel au biser à Paris
dans le 15e qui est un chef qui fait une
très très grande bistronomie et ça je
j'applaudis des demain ce que j'aime pas
c'est voyez ces personnes qui n'ont pas
forcément le talent pour et je leur dis
bah alors faites-nous un bœuf
Bourguignon et on sera très content
d'autant plus que on m'avait parlé d'un
sondage un cabinet de sondage m'avait
dit c'est des chiffres très
approximatifs mais en gros c'est 70 %
des Françaises ne vont que deux fois par
an au restaurant et à cette occasion
dépense 17 € ou moins donc vous voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est que il faut donc
la bistronomie c'est déjà un grand
moment d'aller dépenser 40 € à table et
cetera vous voyez doncon puisse trouver
quelque chose d'assez exceptionnel c'est
un peu dans les grandes villes c'est pas
vraiment exement et quand vous disiez
nous moi je m'attablee souvent dans des
petites tables oui parce que en fait
j'essaie de m'adresser au plus grand
nombre et je ne suis pas du tout contre
les j'ai même filmé un étoilé Michelin
mais mais vous êtes pas très étoilé puis
d'ailleurs on les connaît bien mieux que
les petits que les petits la cuisine du
terroir ou que les petits exactement non
mais j'ai dit en fait ils ont déjà
beaucoup de de ils sont déjà très
médiatiques donc ils ont pas besoin de
ses MC bon pour faire leur publicité et
et puis je pense que il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ne vont jamais dans un nettoyer
de leur vie et s'ils y vont c'est une
une fois ou deux et vous vous regardez
par exemple le prix du restaurant avant
d'y aller en vous disant moi je je reste
à moins de 20 € par exemple je me dis
pas ça je regarde le rapport qualité
prix il y a des restaurants ça vaut 12 €
et c'est super à 12 € et si c'était à 40
ça serait pas bien mais à 12 € c'est
formidable il y a des restaurants comme
les toilets que j'ai filmé la réserve
rimbo à Montpellier il propose un menu à
45 € le midi dans ce cadre- là cette
qualité là qui est pas cher du tout mais
alors je lui avais posé cette question
comment vous arrivez à faire entrer plat
dessert avec ce service l'argenterie la
cristal le cristal et cetera alors qu'à
Paris la veille j'avais mangé un un plat
à 45 € oui mais à Paris là sans doute
que les loyers le peut-être c'est vrai
qu'il y a tout ces considération qui
rentrit dans ses frais qu'il équilibrait
il a dit que c'était forcé non il a dit
que c'était peut-être un menu d'appel
mais que surtout pour pouvoir faire des
prix pas chers il fallait cuisiner et je
l'ai dit dans une interview récemment
j'ai dit quand on n pas d'argent la
solution pour moi c'est de cuisiner
parce que je pense que on va pas un beau
produit les chefs le disent on n pas
besoin de cuisiner alors que quand on a
des pommes de terre pour bluffer
quelqu'un il fautussi mettre un peé
voàisine des bonnes pommes de terre avec
juste un petit peu de beurre ou d'huile
d'olive c'est parfait auss voilà et
quelqu'un par exemple comme guissavis
m'a épaté quand j'avais 20 ans et c'est
peut-être ça qui m'a donné aussi envie
entre autres de faire ce métier c'est
que j'avais mangé chez lui on j'avais
été invité chez guissava pour mes 20 ans
et j'avais mangé une soupe de lentilles
à la TR B elle est très connue c'est de
l la Tru non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que pour arriver à épater pour
arriver à ce prix-l à épater quelqu'un
je il faut beaucoup travailler la
lentille vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est donc vous vous êtes pas
très étoilé on pourrait dire mais
pourtant votre révélation oui en fond
vous l'avez dans un étoilet chez George
blanc j'avais 18 je venais dans le bac
donc voilà et chez George blanc à Vona
parce que je suis regiginère de la
braise de lin dans le département de lin
pardon et de la Dombe je dis la braise
par que je suis né à bourcambbise et
donc mon père m'a dit si tu as une
mention au bac je t'offre un étoilé donc
j'ai travaillé j'ai une mention et j'ai
choisi enfin il m'avait dit voilà c'est
ça il y avit une
carotte non il m'avait dit je t'offre un
TR étoiles et donc j'ai choisi George
blanc parce que j'en avais beaucoup
entendu parler évidemment et et en en
fait je m'attendais à manger quelque
chose d'incroyable et ce qui m'a
bluffé dans son restaurant c'est le le
service et qui a fait qu'après j'ai
voulu faire des études d'ethnologie de
la cuisine pour comprendre qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'était pardon ce service
que je ne soupçonnais pas les cloches
qui se soulève vraiment le balai des
serveurs entre eux qui se regardaient il
se tenait un petit signal et hop il
soulevait les cloches pour qu'il
vraiment synchronis mise scè et là je me
suis dit on est ouais voilà exactement
cette mise en scène pour moi j'ai j'ai
j'ai senti qu'il y avait autre chose
derrière et donc j'ai fait des études au
début je voulais faire une école
hôtelière et j'avais pas envie de faire
de la compable etis tout ce que ça
suppose et donc j'ai commencé des études
d'thnologie quoi alors l'ethnologie de
la cuisine dites-nous et ben en fait il
se trouve que l'ethnologie travaille sur
les différentes cultures dans le Monde
ouais les différentes cultures on va les
étudier et la façon dont on mange est
une des façons de vivre des humains on
peut travailler sur les systèmes de
parenté mais aussi comment mange je sais
pas moi les les Papou en Nouvelle Guinée
voyez et moi j'avais décidé de de
réfléchir à comment on mange les
Français de la haute bourgeoisie et donc
il y a on a un petit peu certains
professeurs m'ont dit oui enfin c'est
pas vraiment etthnologique comme sujet
et puis j'ai trouvé quand même ma
directrice de tè qui était journana
charouti et qui a dit si si tout est
intéressant en fait parce que
effectivement ce que j'ai découvert en
lisant les travaux de Norbert Elias qui
est un un sociologue historien des
manières de table entre autres pas que
c'est que c'est le le rituel du grand
restaurant est emprunté à l'étiquette de
la cour à l'époque de Louis XIV à
Versailles et donc c'était un
un comment un outil de pouvoir pour
Louis XIV sur sa cour et en fait chaque
table dans les grands restaurants c'est
une petite cour enfin c'était mon mon
postulat mon mémoire de maîtrise parce
que j'ai j'ai commencé une thèse mais je
l'ai pas soutenu ensuite sur la
truficulture donc là c'était en maîtrise
d'ethnologie et donc chaque cours est
une chaque table est une petite cour
reconstituée et les les serveurs sont
enfin donc le client et le roi
d'ailleurs les serveurs le disent le
client est roient roi et ma directrice
de tè m'avait dit mais prenez cette
phrase au pied de la lettre et allez
voir ce qui se passait à la cour du roi
et effectivement on retrouve énormément
euh dans les
interactions entre le le le client et le
serveur des usages de l'étiquette quoi
de et vous avez travaillé un an chez
Lucas carton vous avez retrouvé çaement
le client était roi làbas ouais ou ça
respecter ses usages ben par exemple on
ne contredisait jamais le client et je
me souviens lors d'une prise de commande
moi j'enregistrais avec un tout petit
dictaphone discrètement parce qu'il
fallait pas que ça se voit et donc je
sais pas une table commande un poisson
et une viande arrive un poisson et une
viande et un des convives dit non on a
commandé deux poissons donc le maître
d'hôtel dit ben non mais Madame et on
vous dit si madame vous vous dit qu'elle
a commandé un poisson c'est qu'elle a
commandé un poisson hop on remmène tout
donc la panique en cuisine parce qu'il
faut quand même que ça sorte très
rapidement on sert on offre le champagne
au clients pour faire passer la pilule
et après nous quand on a doché j'ai
entendu mais et on m'a dit le client a
toujours raison mais là c'est pas le
client roi c'est le client est chiant
c'est c'est c'est c'est au caprice mais
c'est c'est pour vous dire jusqu'où ça
allait et je pense qu'on ne contredisait
jamais lu 14 en effet et il y avait
énormément de choses comme ça et il y
avait aussi d'autres choses incroybles
c'est qu'il fallait le plus possible
reconnaître donc une fois qu'il s'était
annoncé on faisait d'une manière il y
avait toujours une communication
parallèle par des petits gestes derrière
comme ça que le cent voyait pas tout ce
qu'il avait dit il fallait que ça soit à
qui voilà et donc si Monsieur Dupont
arrivait et que il allait dans un petit
salon on se débrouillait pour faire
passer message que c'était monsieur
Dupont qui arrivait donc quand il
arrivait à l'étage des salon bonjour
monsieur Dupont comme le roi évidemment
on le reconnaissait aussi donc voilà
c'est assez intéressant cette hiérarchie
quoi alors la cuisine est universelle le
fait de se nourrir est universel mais
vous l'ethnologue est-ce que vous avez
trouvé selon des peuples des ethnies des
différences d'appréhension de cette de
cette façon de consommer de cette façon
de cuisiner oui ah bah oui oui bien sûr
parce que d'abord les dégoûts il y a pas
plus compliqué en fait que de s'investir
dans la cuisine de de quelqu'un d'autre
moi j'ai après je suis devenu
journaliste et par exemple j'ai fait un
reportage en Mauritanie et on m'a servi
un C chamelle non ouais un couscous de
boss de Cham
et la bosse de chameau c'est quelque
chose de très gras qui sent très fort
qui sent un peu les pieds je disais et
voyez pour se donner cette cette odeur
Rance un peu et vraiment vous obligé de
le manger je l'ai mangé par par voilà
par correction profnel il fallait manger
avec la main et moi je déteste manger
avec la main parce que j'ai pas cette
habitude Mang
avecousous se mange tradition donc là on
était chez des nomade on avait passé de
jours sous la tente ils ont préparé la
semoule qui avait énormément de de sable
à l'intérieur parce que quand on le Pr
part dans le désert et bah le sable se
mélange mais c'est pas grave il le mange
comme ça et en fait avec la main il
fallait faire une boulette et la manger
moi ça tombait je trouvais ça dégoûtant
et donc je me souviens que la personne
qui m'accompagnait qui était un
Mauritanien du désert il me disait mais
enfin il faut t'habituer son nos
traditions tu dois alors bon je le
faisais et puis après quand on est
retourné dans la ville à côté on a mangé
un poulet rôti comme ça avec je je sais
plus bon des des peut-être des pommes de
terre il a pas aimé et je lui dis tu
vois paril m'a dit c'est pas ça que je
mange c'est pas ma culture mais j'ai dit
tu vois en fait de la même manière que
moi j'ai du mal et je l'ai fait parce
que tu m'as reçu bah toi aussi tu tu as
cette appréhension culturelle c'est pas
voilà c'est ça donc je pense que c'est
la chose la plus
compliqué d'aller manger on est allé
avec un photographe manger
en à Bornéo et en fait on nous a servi
du serpent des autres serpents et tout
ça c'était compliqué j'ai enfin voilà il
a fallu manger mais vous voyez donc
c'est il y a une appréhension c'est
comme aujourd'hui les dégoût éorme fa
voilà les insectes on a une petite
appréhension on en mangera peut-être
tous Demain mais c'est vrai que c'est
bien pour ça que ça prend pas alors que
ça serait peut-être la solution pour
avoir des prot ça c'est des plats de
niche he le serpent moi j'en ai mangé au
Vietnam mais à contrarion on assiste
aussi à une mondialisation de la cuisine
tous les peuples mangent peu auou pro la
même chose aussi maintenant donc pas pas
la même chose mais quand même il y a
une les cuisines étrangères exotiques
fontont ont du succès dans les pays
occidentaux et cetera donc bah alors
c'està dire que oui dans nos pays à nous
mais je veux dire honnêtement pour avoir
beaucoup voyager alors dès qu'on sort
des restaurant un peu occidentaux parce
que c'est l'Occident qui s'exporte et
puis les touristes en fait oui la pizza
ai contonet qui s'exporte aussi oui
c'est vrai mais honnêtement si on
s'enfonce un petit peu dans les
campagnes et quand on voyage moi j'ai
vraiment découvert des choses par
exemple au Cambodge on m'a servi des
tarentules frit c'est compliqué au
characnophobe donc manger sucer des
pâtes de tarentule euh même les méduses
en Chine c'est pas toujours évident ou
ça j'y arrive davantage mais
effectivement c'est pas forcément
évident et puis après bon bah les
Anglais qui arrivent pas à manger des
lapins ou des grenouilles ont parl enfin
voyez donc et et vous votre culture
culinaire elle elle vient d'où qu'est-ce
qu'on mangeait chez chez vous à table
quand on était quand vous étiez enfant
et ben moi je viens de la Bresse et de
la Dombe donc on mangeait des volailles
voilà du poulet le poulet du dimanche
mais comme beaucoup de Français
d'ailleurs on mangeait ma grand-mère mes
deux grand-mères paternell et maternelle
habitaent dans le même village et elle
cuisinaent toutes les deux beaucoup
beaucoup donc une cuisine assez simple
traditionnelle il y avait les deux il y
avait vraiment la cuisine du dimanche un
peu on pouvait faire par exemple un SIV
liè ça prenait 4 jours j mais ça c'était
pour des repas de fête et puis aussi des
cuisinou tout enfin des recettes tout à
fait simple je sais pas une viande
grillée je me souviens en revanche qu'on
mangeait toujours les légumes avant et
ensuite la viande on mangeait jamais
ouais en même temps ou c'est ça et puis
par exemple il y a des traditions comme
ça régional on mange souvent la salade
on la mangeait plutôt en début de repas
quand à Paris je quand je suis arrivé à
Paris on m'a toujours servi la salade
avec le
fromage et oui moi j'aime pas du tout ça
j'aime la manger en entrée ou avec la
viande et ensuite enfin d'abord légumes
et ensuite la viande avec la salade donc
mais c'était c'est surtout qu'on passait
du temps en cuisine on passait du temps
en parler on passa dus vous cuisinez
d'ailleurs vous aimez cuiscoup ou alors
de moins en moins en vieillissant mais à
20 ans je cuisinais des repas incroyable
et tous les gens de la fac venaient chez
moi et disaient quand on va chez elle
c'est génial et tout alors que j'étais
étudiante quel genre quel genre de plat
ah ben je par exemple j'ai commencé à
faire des des alors c'était déjà des
plats un peu traditionnels mais je
faisais des des blanquettes je faisais
des sou bouou j'adorais ça je faisais
des plats mijotés assez longs j'allais
chercher de la bonne viande alors que
j'avais pas pas tellement d'argent parce
que j'étais étudiante mais je mettais un
peu tout là-dedans
et et et et plus le temps passe et moins
j'aime cuisiner en fait plus je ouais
enfin plus je cuisine pensez que ça vous
inspirent vos escapades gourmandes les r
chef oui c'est vrai mais je suis
tellement dans la cuisine et puis
maintenant que je me fil la bouffe oui
voilà exactement je suis tellement dans
les restaurants à me filmer bah dire que
quand j'étais étudiante j'allais pas
beaucoup au restaurant donc on faisait
des repas à la maison aujourd'hui je
fais quand même énormément de
restaurants je sais pas combien mais
plusieurs centaines par an que quand je
rentre chez moi on dit toujours comment
vous gardez la ligne c'est que je ne
mange que quand je suis filmer à présent
donc ça marche alors en revanche pour
accompagner ce plat vous nous avez
proposé un bourgogne donc c'est un naocé
bourgogne à ligoté on est sur des
départements comme Lyon la Côte d'Or la
sonellloire et le rô c'est à peu près
les les quatre départements où on peut
trouver ce ce cespag là ça descend du
pinot noir et euh c'est un millésime
2022 et c'est caractéristiques arôme de
pêche d'abricot de fleurs blanches en
bouche une attaque assez fraîche c'est
dans la place au gras et en final une
puissance minérale qui est assez typique
du terroir c'est pourquoi vous avez
choisi ce vin là parce que j'ai eu un
coup de foudre d'abord il est pas cher
je crois que c'est moins de 10 € la
bouteille donc je trouve que c'est quand
même intéressant de pouvoir acheter
c'est je l' un tout petit peu plus de 10
€ mais c'est autour de 10 € plus moi je
l'ai acheté à nuit-sint-george et il
était à 9 € dans la boutique dans
laquelle je l' acheté la liguté on en
trouve de moins en moins et c'est avec a
ces vins là qu'on faisait le kir le vrai
kir j'adore ça j'adore la Bourgogne
j'adore le toute l'histoire de du cassis
de ce fruits en fait j'adore tout ce qui
me rappelle une région je suis
originaire de La Bresse on s'arrêtait
toujours en Bourgogne quand on
descendait en Dombe avec mon père pour
acheter du vin donc c'est des vrais
souvenir et quand je suis tombée sur
cette ce Bourgogne hicoté là d'abord
parce que on fait de moins en moins de
on fait des kirs avec n'importe quel vin
blanc alors que moi j'aime respectecter
la tradition et et donc voilà et je j'ai
beaucoup aimé je trouve qu'il est il est
très agréable à boire facile je sais pas
je j'aime beaucoup ce vin donc euh bon
rapport qualité prix je me suis dit on
va le mettre en avant et ça se marie
très bien avec le avec le fromage le
comté le chèvre éamment et donc avec ce
cette soupe soupe châéeouais donc on
peut le boire avec ça et puis n'hésitez
pas aussi à l'apéritif avec euh il y a
une ils sont je crois qu'ils sont de la
même famille un producteur de crème de
cassis la ferme fruit rouge et ça a été
un énorme coup de foot dans nos vidéos
l'année dernière euh vraiment on a
l'imessionession de plonger dans un
grain de cassis donc faut retour au kir
ouais au et puis j'allais dire un petit
peu de liquide avec une soupe qui pour
c'est la première fois que je mange une
soupe solide on la mange avec un
couteauou c'est pas la peine de mettre
une cuillère ouais tout à fait donc
peut-être qu'il faut verser un peu de
vin dans la dans la soup dans la soupe
on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable à présent et c'est le
quiz alors Emmanuel vous adorez les
grenouilles surtout celles alors je sais
plus comment on dit de la Dombe ou des
Dombes moi pourtant j'habitais pas très
loin quand j'étais petit on dit la Donon
mais il y a un S alors souvent on dit
parce que le village d'ù je suis
originaire c'est Villard les Donon mais
normalement c'est la don la Dombe donc
celle de la Dombe où habitaent vos
grands-parents vous nous l'avez dit
sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations concernant les batraciens
sont vraie ou fausse au 14e siècle
circulait déjà une recette de pâte de
grenouille farinée puis frit dans le
sein doux vrai ou
faux 14e siècle l'ethnologue
oui je dirais possible oui oui bravo la
grenouille de la Dombe et la rousse
nommée Rana
temporaria vrai ou faux non je dirais
non faux ça c'est celle du Jura dans les
Dombes ou dans la Dombe c'est la verte
la Rana
escouanta dans les années 70 la plupart
des grenouilles consommées en France
sont importé vivantes de youoslavie
ouais c'est possible oui vrai la vente
des grenouilles est interdite depuis
l'an 2000 en France oui faux l'arrêté
qui les protège est plus ancien date de
1980 donc on a on peut pêcher on peut
pêcher des grenouilles pour son son
confort personnel son plaisir mais on ne
peut pas les vendre euh pour
effectivement soutenir l'espèce qui
était en voie de disparition et on verra
tout à l'heure en reportage édifiant
puisque aujourd'hui après la youoslavie
la plupart de nos grenouilles sont é
d'Asie et d'Indonésie en particulier
d'accord alors trois bonnes réponses sur
quatre c'est déjà très bien deuxème quiz
vous avez découvert l'univers de la
gastronomie chez George blanc on le
disait tout à l'heure à Vona vonas Vona
von sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses sa
mère appelée la mère blanc a fait partie
de l'âge d'or des mères lyonnaises en
cuisine avec les mères Jean brziier et
Bernard oui faux la mère bourgeois à la
place de la mère Bernard c'était la mer
Jean BR ah je pensais est-ce qu'elle a
fait partie de des de la la question
est-ce qu'elle faisait partie des mer
lionnaises non c'était les nom
d'accord pièg il y a des
pièges j'éta obligé de mettre des pièges
parce que TR c'est trop FA outeux la
merè blanc ellisa est désignée meilleure
cuisinière du monde en
1933 alors c'est la date c'est sur cette
date vous me posez la question je sais
qu'elle a eu deux étoiles en 1933 au
guide Michelin et c'est kurnnonski qui
l'avait désigné du monde mais est-ce que
c'est en 33
euh non pas en 33
si allez George blanc qui l'a remplacé
décroche la 3è étoile en 1970 18 on
parle de la date 1978 là on est sur la
date ah la date oh là
là vraiment au pif oui non parce qu'il
reprend je crois qu'il reprend le
restaurant en 78 et il attend quelques
années kski c'était très bien c'était
plus dur que la date de savoir que
cétait C 33 elle a eu ses deux étoiles
parce que c'est l'année où toutes les M
sont rentré la mer bras a eu TR étoiles
allez la dernière question mais là vous
allez spécialité était la quenelle de
cendre en viennoise vrai ou faux non je
dirais non non c'est faux effement
l'éclaté deomar au vin jaune et F
ravolle à l'oseille voilà vous vous
souvenez de ce que vous avez mangé chez
George blanc ah oui je s m mélo
printanier au citron confi un cendre au
savanien un omble chevalier ah oui un
Omble chevalierou ça c'est un poisson d'
douce non ouais tout à fait et je
connaissais rien de tout ça je savais
pas que le savanien c'était un sépage je
savais pas que l'omble chevalier était
un poisson ce qui fait que quand c'est
arrivé je me suis dit mais j'ai commandé
un omble chevalier j'ai vu un poisson
arriver j'ai pas osé dire mais non j'ai
pas commandé ça vous vous souvenez du
menu de vos 18 ans ouais mais ça c'est
bon signe hein parce que quand on se
souvient comme ça du du restaurant parce
que souvent dans les grands restaurants
on est un peu perdu je me souviens plus
c'est comme les blagues on s souvient
plus oui voilà soup sauvage glacé au
solilais je ne savais pas ce qui était
les solilais comment ça s'écrivait et
tout non mais ça a été une telle
sidération ce moment que voilà alors
c'est souvent autour de la table autour
d'un déjeuner que se raconte les
meilleures histoires et c'est la bref de
comptoir alors Emmanuel Jarry on vous a
demandé de de vous souvenir d'une d'une
anecdote autour d'un d'un repas est-ce
qu'il y a une un souvenir que vous avez
à nous raconter mais alors je me
souviens d'un tournage qui a été très
marquant pour nous puisquon en a parlé
c'est chez rwan le restaurateur à
Bourdonnais dans les Yvelines qui nous a
fait connaître puisqu'on a fait tant de
vues et eu 4 milli 40 millions tout à
fait c'est c'est énorme 40 millions
ouais c'était oui c'est assez fou ouais
sur 78 millions de Français mal mais
parce qu'on a suivi les réseaux sociaux
vous savez ça part à l'étranger parce
qu'il y a des personnes qui m'ont dit
l'avoir vu en Argentine et tout ça en
fait on m'a souvent demandé pourquoi
cette vidéo là alors c'est sûr que lui
c'est un personnage mais il se trouve
trouve que dans cette vidéo j'ai eu une
petite émotion que je n'ai pas réussi à
cacher parce que ça m'a rappelé on
parlait de mes grands-parents les les
les repas Dominico chez mes
grands-parents ou quand on allait chez
George blanc dans la petite auberge et
donc j'ai j'ai j'ai eu les les yeux un
peu brillants et Mathieu penscer qui me
filme l'a vu et il en a parlé et ça a
fait couler une larme que j'ai essuyé et
que j'avais dit je refuse de garder ça
au montage parce que ça me gênait de
montrer cette émotion c'est quelque
chose de personnel et Matthieu m'a
convaincu de la garder et je crois qu'on
a bien fait parce que on tellement parl
ça a participé à diffuser en fait cette
vidéo et en fait je pense que c'est ça
aussi qui caractérise on dit souvent
mais pourquoi vos vidéos elle marche et
tout c'est que Matthieu m'a dit sois
sincère dis ce que tu penses donc on on
prépare rien et quand je suis devant un
PL voilà je suis comme là comme avec
vous et en
fait donc voilà et cette larme le prouve
en fait j'ai j'ai essayé de la cacher
j'ai pas réussi quand elle a coulé j'ai
fait ça et bah le geste on le voit et
voilà et ça a fonctionné 40 millions de
vues ça veut dire aussi que émotion est
très est très liée à la table et à ce
qu'on mange ou au souvenir que ce que
l'on mange rappelle donc c'est
intéressant aussi ouais bah complètement
c'est une émotion et c'est aussi ça sans
doute que qui a fait le succès de oui
oui je crois que c'est ça en fait il y a
plein de gens qui se sont reconnus
là-dedans parce qu'on a tous ressenti ça
prou le premier hein quand j'ai lu ce
passage de la Madeleine à 15 ans je me
suis dit c'est tellement extraordinaire
quand parfois on a quelque chose qui
nous percute les papis ou même parfois
ça peut être une odeur et ça nous
transporte c'est c'est plus que de le
souvenir on revit l'instant c'est ce qui
décrit très très bien je suis pas
prousse donc je le dis moins bien mais
en tout cas et donc je crois que les
gens se sont reconnus là-dedans parce
qu'on a déjà tousu si on boit un petit
verre de blanc en plus euh une émotion à
table comme ça de j'ai dit on ne guérit
jamais de son enfance donc c'était un
peu ça ce qui s'exprimait dans cette
vidéo qui fait qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
critique culinaire et sur les réseaux
sociaux on en trouve beaucoup des
critiques culinaires comme vous et aussi
des influenceurs quelle différence
peut-on les croire quand ils donnent
leur avis le dessous des
plats
la cuisine grande star des réseaux
sociaux les vidéos des influenceurs food
font parfois des millions de VU résultat
les restaurateurs courent après une
chronique pour augmenter leur clientèle
tout est fait pour rendre et bien
l'offre alléchante Clément per et Ivan
anavion nous mettent l' à la
bouche ils sont là pour vous faire
saliver en ligne et accessoirement
consomm les amateurs de Fran 100%
classique celle-ci c'est vraiment celle
qu'il vous faut sur les réseaux sociaux
il partagent le bon plan resto ou
produits voyage culinaire le tout dans
une ambiance ultra positive tu vas voir
c'est juste une dinguer on les appelle
les influenceur food même si eux
préfèrent le terme de
créateur parmi les conttes les plus
suivi celui d'Alexis thbo baptisé le
Paris d'Alexis 315000 abonnés il est
aujourd'hui dans un resto parisien qu'il
vient découvrir et faire
découvrir alors pour l'entrée on est sur
mélange sucré salé qui est vraiment
hyper équilibré l'assassina elle est
extrêmement fine limite elle fond sur la
langue c'est très agréable micro sur le
col et smartphone à la main Alexis
connaît par cœur les recettes pour faire
du clic sur les réseau il faut capter
l'attention des gens dans les 5
premières secondes sinon il swipe et
encore quand je dis 5 c'est plutôt dans
les TR premières secondes donc faut être
assez percutant dès le
début ces vidéos tournent souvent autour
de 200000 vues et peuvent régulièrement
dépasser le million pour les
restaurateurs peuvent constituer une
formidable
publicitéise bond chef du restaurant et
ancien candidat de l'émission Top Chef
en est bien
consci
j en gros il pêch pas un poisson parce
gros ils on il tout un filet derrière
ils ont attrapé pas mal de personnes qui
é prêt à regarder ce
comp si alexis est toujours invité par
les restaurants la plupart DEES vidéos
ne don pas lieu à une rémunération
l'essenti
de spécifi commandé par des marques on
appelle cela des
collab si les grosses écuries de
l'alimentaire reste le cœur de ce marché
de petits restaurants commencent
également à ouvrir leur portefeuille
pour profiter des réseaux des
influenceurs c'est le cas de cet
établissement parisien au pied de la
butte Montmartre ok Sébastien cardinal
qui tient un compte spécialisé dans la
cuisine végane est venu présenter un
burger dont il a concocté la recette et
qui sera ajouté pour quelques semaines à
la carte je pense que je vais le manger
à la main c'est un test c'est un crash
test c'est avec vous on va voir est-ce
que j'en mets partout est-ce que c'est
sale est-ce que c'est
décadent on espère l'influenceur
touchera 1 € par burger vendu sa vidéo
sera diffusé en cross po c'est-à-dire en
même temps sur son compte et sur celui
du restaurant qui peut ainsi gagner des
abonnés donc pour être connecté avec ta
clientèle et ta communauté il faut être
présent sur les réseaux sociaux il faut
s'intéresser il faut au P c'est que ta
communauté ou tes clients sont
intéressés de
entendre le compte Instagram de ce
restaurant dépasse désormais les 11000
abonnés son recours fréquent à des
influenceurs n'y est pas pour
rien Emmanuel jar vous vous êtes
critique culinaire est-ce qu'il y a une
différence entre critique culinaire et
influenceur food bah c'estire qu'à
présent je crois que je suis devenue
influenceuse on m'a souvent posé la
question maintenant j'avais une carte de
presse je l'ai rendu et
oui il y a quand même une une différence
parce que quand on est critique on
critique en positif ou en négatif on
teste et puis on dit j'ai aimé j'ai pas
aimé par exemple François Simon à
l'époque du Figaro voilà c'était
vraiment un critique où il donnait son
avis euh fa toujours il le fait toujours
oui tout à fait mais vous c'est plutôt
positif moi c'est toujours positif on a
fait une vidéo négative mais comme une
vidéo c'est 4 jours de travail entre le
tournage le montage et cetera à la fin
avec Mathieu on s'est dit est-ce qu'on
fait 4 jours pour dire n'y allit pas non
donc en fait quand on nime pas on n
parle pas et puis en plus de temp
appemment moi je suis plutôt joyeuse et
tout ça et donc j'aime m'enthousiasmer
et quand j'aime pas je sais pas quoi
dire donc voilà on a choisi de ne parler
que de ce qu'on aime mais là je parle
d'influenceur parce que on les voit il y
a parfois du placement produit il y a de
la publicité c'est comme ça aussi qu'ils
sont rémunérés c'est quoi votre modèle
économique à vous et bien nous en fait
on fait des par alors on a les produits
dérivés comme les revues les livres et
puis on fait des partenariats avec les
régions la ligne qu'on ne dépassera
jamais c'est que contrairement à
l'influenceur qu'on a vu jamais je ne me
ferai payer par un restaurant
bah les restaurants nous demandent
parfois des grands groupes en fait enous
disant combien c'est pour avoir une
vidéo ça c'est il y a pas de
tarif vous payez votre repas et je paye
mon repas ça c'est bon ça c'est pas
grand chose non non mais oui mais lui il
le fait pas oui oui non seulement il le
PE pas mais en plus on le paye pour
faire ça moi j'ai dit non jamais je
dépasser oui oui non mais alors ça me
pose aucun problème mais moi c'est la
ligne rouge parce que je suis pas sûr
que le restaurant paye Alexis ah non il
touche 1 € par non ça c'est le
deuxème Alex dit qu'il paye pas son menu
mais je pense pas qu'il est rémunéré par
le vous vous êtes invité j'imagine
parfois non vous vous tenez forc oui al
en fait maintenant ils veulent toujours
nous inviter on refuse parce qu'on a dit
bon voilà maintenant on a cette ligne de
enfin cette règle donc on l'applique à
tout le monde et parfois il faut
vraiment se battre pour payer l'addition
et et donc voilà et même je dis écoutez
ils veulent m'offrir la moitié non non
parce que à la fin on met le le ticket
de C et les gens ils ont envie de voir
combien tout ce qu'ils ont vu combien ça
a coûté ça c'est très important alors on
mofre le café bon voilà mais c'est les
publicités qui qui avant ou après en fa
voilà quand les vidéos sont très virales
vidéo à 40 millions de vues voyez ça
fait quand même un peu de enfin voilà MT
vous reverse comme ça parce qu'ils
mettent des publicités au début donc ça
c'est une partie de notre modèle
économique les produits dérivés et après
des partenariats avec les régions moi
j'ai contacté les régions en leur disant
je peux mettre en avant votre territoire
en revanche on avit fait un gros
partenariat avec la Bretagne il y a 2
ans on a fait 6 ou 7 vidéos mais j'ai
dit vous me dites pas où je vais je vais
en Bretagne mais je fais à ma manière et
ils ont dit d'accord et je crois qu'on
avait touché 10 millions de personnes
sur cette campagne donc mais j'avais
choisi les resturant
non ça ça me PLA pas ah ouais c'est vous
qui choisissez bah oui parce qu'en fait
je dis sinon allez j'avais fait un autre
partenariat avec la Ville de Lille qui
voulait que je filme des étoilet mais
j'ai dit alleer chercher les gens qui
filment les étoilets vous venez pas me
chercher moi si vous vlez me chercher
moi laissez-moi faire à ma manière et
donc ils ont accepté c'était formidable
quoi on a vraiment fait vous pourriez
accepter de faire de la publicité comme
le fait Alexis par exemple avec un
produit de marque et on vous voit goûter
ce produit pour l'instant on a refusé on
nous l'a proposé pour l'instant non
parce que en fait je pouris non je
pourrais accepter si c'était des prod
produit qui me plaisent mais comme c'est
l'agroalimentaire et c'était des
produits qui me plaisaient pas et que je
mange pas moi j'ai pas eu envie en fait
on m'a proposé oui des publicités pour
des des marques qui me plaisait pas donc
j'ai dit non mais on a quand même un
annonceur on aussi jour où la marque
vous pla il y a plein de chefs qui font
des pubs pour des des produits qui sain
bon et on le voit dans mes vidéos c'est
que nous on fait des des vidéos au
restaurant mais on fait aussi des
recettes on a commencé pendant le
confinement comme les restaurants étent
fermés on s'est mis à faire ça pour
rigoler ça a tellement bien marché que
maintenant on fait les deux et ben Smeg
la marque Smeg est notre annonceur et
notre partenaire officiel et sponsorise
toutes les vidéos et c'est marqué au
début il y a pas de voilà et je cuisine
dans une cuisine smake donc voilà mais
puce que la marque me plaisait je trouve
ça très beau alors frigo vous vous avez
vous avez conscience de l'influence que
vous pouvez avoir sur pour faire et
défaire des notoriétés ça ça vous ça
vous freine parfois dans non c'est c'est
pas toujours facile de dire ce qu'on
pense parce que par oui mais moi je ne
défais rien donc ça me freine pas si si
effectivement je faisais de la critique
négative ça pourrait être un peu
problématique pour moi parce que j'ai
même quelqu'un qui travaille très mal
j'ai j'ai pas envie de vider son
restaurant s'il est plein je m'en fiche
il vit comme il a envie de vivre et
c'est pas à moi de juger mais étant
donné que nous on conseille récemment en
fait on m'a invité un des journalistes
m'a' m'ainvité dans une crêpe de la
revue dans une crêperie et qui marchait
pas très bien et c'était absolument
excellent donc j'ai dit on va faire une
vidéo et à présent elle ne peut plus
ouvrir midi et soir parce qu' il y a
tellement d'affluence qu'elle n'arrive
plus à faire de la pâte à crêpe pour les
deux services donc elle n'ouvre que le
midi et et et là là c'est quoi le secret
pour faire du clic comment vous avez
réussi à faire de cette crêperie où il y
avait personne un lieu h fréquenté et
ben parce qu'en fait on est suivi par 2
millions de personnes enfin on a 2
millions d'abonnés sur l'ensemble des
réseaux et donc les vidéos bah voilà
elle a fait cré une communauté ou voilà
tout à fait et là récemment pardon on a
filmé dans le Cantal on a posté la vidéo
il y a 15 jours et j'ai eu un message
hier du chef qui m'a dit ça y est je
suis plein à 15 jours le téléphone n pas
arrêté de sonner et alors lui il avait
pas de problème de fréquentation encore
que la semaine parfois ça pouvait être
donc moi je suis ravie en fait et il y a
des restaurants à présent sachant cette
affluence là qui m'ont qui ont refusé
que je les filme en me disant je
pourrais pas tenir choc et je trouve ça
bien parce que ça sert à rien s'il
refuse après les appels quoi
l'ethnologue que vous êtes comment vous
analysz cette passion des réseaux
sociaux pour la nourriture de Jakarta
angoulem en passant par San Francisco et
Moscou c'est universel ça pour le coup
ouais comment vous comment vous
l'analysez bah ça prouve quand même
cette universalité ça prouve qu'il y a
une occidentalisation du monde parce que
ça passe quand même par Instagram les
réseaux sociaux enfin tous les les
réseaux sociaux parce que je pense que
quand même les les gens qui qui vivent
encore au finfond de l'Amazonie ils ont
pas forcément cette donc je pense qu'il
ça prouve aussi que M est portable même
très loin même reculer ouou oui mais
est-ce qu' il filme des mais alors je
sais pas pourquoi quand j'ai commencé
mes études d'ethnologie sur la cuisine
mes profs me disaient oui bon c'est vrai
que la cuisine c'est important mais
enfin bon il faudrait trouver des sujets
sérieux voyez c'est la Gourmandie c'est
un vilain défaut quoi on est quand même
dans une société vidéoch chrétienne et
donc je disais bah non je comprenais pas
et maintenant je j'ai pas regardé
récemment les travaux des ethnologues ou
des étudiants mais je pense qu'il y a
énormément de gens qui travaillent sur
la cuisine je je sais sais pas
l'analyser je comprends pas pourquoi il
y a eu cette cette mondialisation enfin
cet engouement incroyable je sais pas
l'analyser Brigit rest où on rentre sans
que quelqu'un prenne la photo du plat
moi le premier parfois mais c'est j'ai
honte parfois de me dire pourquoi je
pense ce plat en photo mais au départ
quand je ouais tout à fait et en fait au
départ moi j'étais gêné je le faisais je
me cachais un peu parce que je trouvais
ça affreux alors maintenant très
décomplexé je prends toutes les photos
parprès il faut que j'annonce un vra pou
aller des chefs qui sont furiieux he
d'ailleurs ou je comprends il y a un
restaurant en Italie où je suis allé il
y a quelques années il y a des petites
il y a des petites boîtes et on met son
portable à l'entrée et on ferme à clé
alors respect on fait le chef quand même
mettre à bord donc c'est lui qui décide
quoi c'est son œuvre voilà non mais
c'est en tout cas c'est un lieu privé
donc il fait il fait ce qu'il veut chez
lui alors vous nous disiez début de
cette émission petite vous aimiez manger
des des cuisses de grenouillees mais
saviez-vous qu'elle venaient peut-être
de l'autre bout du monde et qu'elles
étaient tuées dans des conditions
atroces on en parle et on met les pieds
dans le
plat
alors vous le savez les Français ont à
l'étranger la réputation de mangeur de
grenouilles frogs réputation à peine
exagérée car la France est le premier
importateur de ces délicieux batraciens
mais derrière l'assiette de cuisse de
grenouille en persillade se cache une
réalité sombre comme vient de le montrer
une enquête en décembre de l'ONG PETA
qui lutte contre la maltraitance animale
c'est un reportage de France Télévision
avec Hélène Bonduel et Marion
duvuchel c'est l'une des spécialités de
ce restaurant
l'un des plfards de la gastronomie
française les cuisses de grenouilles on
met juste les grenouilles dans la farine
on fait chauffer du beurre clarifié ça
c'est de l'ail on a mixé dernière étape
un peu de
persil une recette testé souvent avec
curiosité par les touristes
[Musique]
étrangers ça ne ressemble à rien de ce
que j'ai déjà mangé c'est vraiment
unique comme goût unique et pourtant pas
si français que ça
la quasi-ttalité des cuisses de
grenouilles consommées en France est
importée principalement d'Indonésie
première exportateur mondial des
amphibiens souvent capturés dans la
nature même si c'est interdit et dans
des conditions d'abattage dénoncé par
cette association de défense des animaux
là bon ben on voit toutes les
grenouilles qui sont dans des sacs
bondés les unes sur les autres les
grenouilles respirent par leur peau fait
quand elles sont les unes sur les autres
elles étouffent des fois elle reste
jusqu'à 2 jours dans ses sacs on leur
coupe les pâtes elles sont encore
vivantes quand on leur coupe la tête si
elle est mal coupée elle continue à
respirer là on voit la grenouille qui
bouge encore et qui respire encore et
qui tremble alors qu'on l' à moitié
décapité c'est des animaux qui sont
sensibles qui ont un système nerveux qui
qui ressentent la douleur comme nous la
branche Asie de l'association a enquêté
3 ans dans une dizaine de centres
d'abattage à Java Bali ou sous Matra les
Gon qui provienent d'Indonésie c'est
majoritairement des grenouilles sauvages
qui sont capturé dans les marais les
enfin dans la nature euh il faut savoir
aussi que les grenouilles c'est c'est
des animaux extrêmement importants pour
la biodiversité parce qu'ils mangent des
insectes et que s'il y a plus de
grenouilles pour manger des insectes ben
il y a trop d'insectes s'il y a trop
d'insectes on met des pesticides et si
on met trop de pesticides on
s'empoisonne donc en fait c'est ce qui
s'est passé par exemple en Inde au
départ les grenouilles qu'on consommé en
France à provenait de France on s'est
rendu compte que ça posait problème on a
interdit la la capture de grenouilles et
donc ensuite on est allé servir en Inde
s'est passé la même chose en Inde donc
ensuite on est allé en Indonésie là il
est en train de se passer la même chose
en Indonésie et l'étape suivante ils
vont aller en Turquie il va se passer la
même chose en Turquie des étiquettes
mensongères sur l'origine et les espèces
de grenouilles des problèmes de
tracabilité petafance a enquêté auprès
de la grande distribution française
plusieurs distributeurs ont depuis
suspendu ou arrêter leurs importations
depuis ses abattoirs indonésiens
d'autres part comme C enseigne
spécialisé dans les surgelés
Emmanuel Jarry dans numéro 2 de votre
revue La Question à la Une était faut-il
mettre du sentiment dans nos assiettes
est-ce que vous allez maintenant mettre
du sentiment dans votre assiette quand
on va vous servir des cues de grenouille
oui dans T dans tous les cas moi je
pense qu'il faut faire attention à ce
qu'on mange cependant juste un tout
petit bémol j'ai beaucoup pêché la
grenouille quand j'étais euh en Dombe
donc pour notre consommation personnelle
puis qu'on nait pas le droit de de les
vendre et euh on donc ma grand-mère
quand on lui rapportait des grenouilles
elle coupait la tête comme ça sans de la
même façon que les Indonésiens le font
et alors là je sais pas parce qu'il
Contin continu à bouger les grenouilles
continuent à bouger pourtant ilells
avaient la tête coupée parce que c'est
le
côté le NG explique qu' les coupe mal il
les coupe pas assez derrière l'oreille
donc il les tu pas sur le le voilà après
nous avec mon père on a commencé à
trouver ça cruel donc on les assommait
euh avant de leur couper la tête et de
les dépesser euh et on les avait on les
mettait dans des grands sacs comme ça en
toile de jus qu'on appelait des troubles
c'est un terme pas toi et donc elles
étaient parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
les rattrapait après avoir Ferré la en
fait elles mordent on ferre elles font
un volpané et on les rattrape il y a
toute une dextérité du pêcheur de
grenouille et donc elles sontassai
effectivement dans ces SAS sauf qu'au
lieu de rester de jours nous elle
restait 3h et après on les tuait mais
donc voilà c'est tué un animal oui
jamais je enfin moi j'ai j'ai je le dis
je je mange de la viande je mange du
poisson mais effectivement la souffrance
animale c'est un vrai sujet je trouve ça
grave je crois que c'est Gandy qui
disait qu'on on mesure le degré de
civilisation d'un d'un peuple à la façon
dont il traite ses animaux et je crois
que c'est vrai donc euh là c'est
effectivement vous aviez connaissance de
la façon dont on les traité non je
savais pas mais ça m'étonne qu'à moitié
Z je on a été tellement loin dans la
dans l' c'est de qui de l'Indonésie ou
ou de ceux qui importent comme nous
parce qu'on est le premier importateur
de grenouille et ben les deux c'est
d'abord l'Indonésie qui
devrait proposer des grenouilles qui
sont pêchées enfin d'ailleurs je croyais
que c'était des élevages là j'ai eu les
Captur c'est très compliqué les élevage
de grenouilles parce qu'elle se barrent
elle sauteent les barrières ça c'est des
des grenouilles qu'on qu'on va pêcher
dans les étend dans les dans les lacs de
d'Indonésie suatra B et non mais en plus
si ça met en péril la biodiversité vous
savez moi j'ai dit j'arrête de manger
des avocats parce qu'en fait c'est très
gourmand en eau et qu'il y a des
problèmes avec les nafratis donc je
serais capable d'arrêter de manger c'est
importé et tout ça donc je serais
capable d'arrêter de manger des
grenouilles même si j'adore ça euh parce
que on me dit que c'est des grenouilles
qui sont pas euh faudrait arrêter d'en
nimporter en France euh bah en tout cas
faut choisir les bonnes filières parce
que je pense qu'il doit y avoir des
bonnes filières et qu tant pis que ça
devienne un produit de luxe et que on en
est voyez mais pas que voilà de toute
manière il faut faire attention à la
filière qui est une transparence et
savoir d'où ça vient comment évidemment
à toutes les étapes comment c'est
comment s pêché comment s'est tué
comment s'est transformé mais on peut
s'étonner que le législateur ne soit pas
intervenu parce que là on voit que c'est
les marques de grande distribution qui
de leur propres chef ne prennent plus je
pense qu'il faudrait que la dgccf jette
un il ou une une législation pour dire
interdiction d'importer des grenouilles
qui sont tués dans ces conditions
parceut a souvent trompré sur les
étiquettes elle le dit dans le reportage
oui c'est ça alors après bah si on est
un des plus plus gros le reportage le
dit un des plus gros importateurs en
Europe c'est ça ou dans le monde en
Europe France premiier pays importateur
moi j'ai vu en France la France le prix
prier
quiorte M grenouill oui mais je me disis
qu'on en mange tant que ça jeend pas
compte parce Queen fait moi sorti de la
don j'en jamais à la carte des
restaurants vous envoyez souvent desou
et bizarrement quand je suis pas en
Dombre je peux pas manger de grenouille
sous non parce que il y en a beaucoup
surgelé dans les supermarchés il y a
beaucoup de il y a une grande enseigne
de surgelé qui ouais c'est ça c'est pas
très compliqué mais autant les escargots
je les vois beaucoup dans à Paris ou
ailleurs autant les grenouilles j'avoue
que c'est on en voit moins y en a quand
même pas mal et puis les les les
consommateurs qui les achètent eux-mêmes
la grande distribution C ces marques
indonésiennes sont desstinées à la grand
grand distribution ou c'est ça alors
c'est vrai que moi je n'ai jamais acheté
de grenouilles parce que je ne les mange
qu'au restaurant et je ne les mange
qu'en Dombe et on avait même une
expression métonymique dans chez moi
pour dire on va au restaurant on disait
on va manger les grenouilles ça voulait
dire on va manger au restaurant et pas
forcément des grenouilles mais c'était
voilà parce y avait toujours des
grenouilles en entrée et vous en mangez
aujourd'hui régulièrement ou bah non
parce que je ne vais plus en Dombe donc
non ça fait plusieurs années que j'ai
pas mangé de grenouilles mais quand je
suis allé tourner à Lyon dans un petit
bistro où la la femme était donb il y
avait des grenouilles tout de suite si
je mais je les aime tel qu'elles sont
fait là-bas en persiade et encore une
fois je les aime là-bas je mangerai
jamais des grenouilles à Bordeaux quoi
je voilà alors on va on a fini on va
passer au dessert à présent et c'est le
pécher
mignon avec Brigit régressif classique
qui sent bon le déjeuner familial et
dominical une bonne mousse au chocolat
alors valeur sûre pour les gourmands et
culte pour les amateurs ou les accros à
la tablette noire 70 % la petite
histoire Brigitte dit que c'est le
cuisinier Suisse Charles F qui elle a
inventé cette mousse au chocolat pour
notre roi Louis X elle s'appelle d'abord
mousse de chocolat parce qu'on se
demande si c'est pas plutôt la mousse
qui est extraite d'un chocolat qui est
déjà chauffé et cetera c'est plutôt vers
1820 qu'elle devient une vraie recette à
base de choc chocolat de jaune d'œuf de
crème et de sucre ce qui va contribuer à
populariser ce dessert on prête aussi à
Toulouse l'Autrec l'invention de la
recette comportant du cacao du blanc
d'œuf monté en neige et du beurre alors
Emmanuel Jarry quel est le secret d'une
bonne mousse au chocolat du dimanche
pour la faire ou à quoi elle doit quel
goû elle doit avoir moi déjà j'aime
quand elle qu'elle est mousseuse parce
que parfois on a des mousses au chocolat
on va goûter
celle-ci peuent être très compact assz
compact
compa ah non ça va quand même non parce
que il faut pas non plus que ce soit du
vent il faut qu'il y ait quelque chose
en bouche que ouais mais je la je la
rangerai même si je veux pas juger je la
trouve bonne chocé mais je la trouve
plutôt compactene ah oui moi je moi je
trouve ça va là ce degré de de mousse et
de compacte mais ce que je trouve très
bon c'est qu'elle est compacte aussi un
petit peu mais moi j'aime bien surtout
elle est très chocolaté oui donc vous
vous aimé quand elle il y a beaucoup
quoi 70 % de chocolat non 70 ou quand il
y a peu de sucre un chocolat qui a
beaucoup de de goût et qui une certaine
amertume h j'aime pas du tout le sucre
et je ne mange quasiment jamais dessert
sauf les desserts au chocolat et le neck
plus ultra pour moi esttant la mousse
donc voilà c'est pour ça que je vous ai
demandé votre avis il doit y avoir les
jaunes là non pour qu'elle soit un peu
compacte pour qu'elle soit compact comme
ça c'est pas impossible ou alors il peut
y avoir un peu de soit de la crème soit
du beurre en théorie euh vous mettez de
la crème et du beurre dans la moi je
suis bressane j'en mets un peu partout
un peu partout il m'arrive parfoit d'en
mettre mais ce que j'aime beaucoup là
c'est les petits copos qui apportent du
croquant parce que ce qui est
intéressant dans les desserts souvent
c'est les textures h je trouve que vous
êtes dur avec cette mousse au chocolat
non non non on je la trouve très très
bonne très chocolatée je la trouve si on
doit la distinguer compacte ou légère je
la trouve plutôt dans la fam des compact
ou oui mais un bon degré de compact donc
vous vous l'aimez un peu amélioré avec
des petites ouais j'aime ça mais j'aime
pas quand il y a des fruits j'aime pas
quand il y a de l'alcool voilà j'aime le
chocolat pur et dur pour moi ouais le
chocolat pour moi c'est vraiment une
drogue j'en mange toute la journée toute
la journée alors sous forme de de
tblette ouais de tablett ouais ouais à
mon bureau ouais j'ai toujours des
tablettes dans mes tiroirs mes collègues
le savent ils viennent m' piquer et donc
oui oui je peux pas me passer de
chocolat on commence à quoi à 70 % ou
ouais que 70 % et je vais pas plus de 75
parce qu'en fait je trouve que c'est le
bon ce que me disait Stéphane Bonac un
chocolatier avec qui j'ai voyagé on est
allé dans plantation et tout ça qui est
vraiment un quelqu'un qui est passionné
parce qu'il va chercher des crus et puis
il Conche le conchage c'est vraiment la
chose la plus importante il y a très peu
il y a peut-être si six chocolat qui bah
c'est la transformation de la f une
étape ouais de la transformation et qui
va donner cette texture bon dans le
chocolat souvent en fait il y a eu aussi
une mode du chocolat partout dans le
monde des gens qui sont mis à faire ce
qu'on appelle le bean to bar quoi de de
la de la fève jusqu'à la tablette mais
en fait il leur manque cette étape qui
fait qu'il y a quelque chose de soyeux
en bouche de la tablette quoi et et donc
pourquoi je vous disais ça je me suis
perdu en tout cas oui 75 % c'est le pour
moi c'est l'équilibre voà entre
l'amertum parce qu' après on retrouve à
90 % je trouve que c'est pas intéressant
puis il y a un côté rugueux dans en
bouche et moins ben je il y a moins pas
assez de chocolat donc voilà 75 15 %
c'est bien et donc sinon jamais de
dessert non j'aime pas trop j'y arrive
he mais j'avoue que le sucre c'est un
problème pour moi ouais j'aime pas le
goût sucré sauf le choc oui donc quand
on goûte quand on va au restaurant
difficile pour vous de juger les de
juger les dessertsit non j'ai de la
chance parce qu'il y a très souvent des
desserts au chocolat dans tous les
restaurants parce que je pense que je
sais plus quel chocolatier disait que 9
Français sur 10 aiment le chocolat et le
10è qui dit ne pas aimer il ment donc
voilà en fait je crois que tout le monde
aime le chocolat et quand il y en a pas
euh bon je tente un peu quelque chose
mais c'est vrai que je j'ai du mal avec
le sucre et ça depuis enfant he j'ai
mangais jamais jamais mangé beaucoup de
sucre comment vous jugez ces pâtisseries
de plus en plus sophistiqué ces
pâtissiers ou pâtissière on pense à Nina
métaayer de plus en plus médiatique qui
voilà qui sont des stars maintenant et
qui font plus des gâteaux mais quasiment
des œuvres d'art est-ce que ça vous
impressionne est-ce que vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne chose pour la
patriisserie ou au contraire on change
de registre on nose même plus les manger
ces gâteau oui c'est vrai et il y a
c'est cric Gret qui avait fait un rubit
SCUP je trouve extraordinaire et je sais
que je l'aimerais pas je l'ai jamais
mangé mais j'adorais quand même croquer
dedans parce que je le trouve beau je le
trouve appétissant je trouve ça
complètement fascinant d'arriver c'est
quand même là on est vraiment dans du la
maîtrise incroyable du sucre d'arriver à
faire quelque chose qui ressemble aussi
aussi de façon aussi fidèle à la chose
qui est représentée donc ça ça peut être
des fruits le rubit CU et ca donc moi ça
m'attire pas gustativement mais je
trouve que c'est un peu comme Anton
carem qui faisait au 19e des des plats
tout en hauteur et ben c'est une autre
ça s'inscrit dans l'histoire de la cuine
française donc je crois que c'est un
moment important en fait et que on peut
analyser vous trouvez pas qu'il y a une
tendance aussi actuellement vers des des
desserts avec très peu de sucre il y a
des des grands chefs qui aujourd'hui
proposent des DESS qui sont à peine
sucrés oui alors ça je trouve ça super
parce que comme moi j'aime pas trop le
sucre moins c'est sucré plus j'arrive
aller manger à vous just exactement mais
vous savez en fait quand je mange dans
des dans des maisons d'autes des des
desserts de de grand-mère souvent c'est
très peu sucré il y a eu un peu une
dérive où on s'est mis à sucrer parce
que bah les gens aiment le sucre et tout
mais là on revient vers ça et j'aime
beaucoup chez certains pâtissiers c'est
que ils se remettent à faire des fruits
de saison parce que on parle toujours
des produits de saison mais vous avez
des tartes aux fraises aux framboises
toute l'année dans les pâtisseries dans
plein de pâtisseries et donc maintenant
il y a toute une mouvance comme ça de
pâtissiers qui dit non non on va
respecter les saisons et ben oui
pourquoi on respecterait pas aussi les
saisons pour les tartes aux fraises et
les tartes aux framboises et l'hiver
faire des tartes aux pommes enfin voyez
donc ça je trouve c'est c'est bien alors
souvent ce sont des fruits congelés
parce que quand on va au ski l'hiver
qu'on mange une tarte au MITI alors de m
de neige dehors on se dit que ouais
c'est ça alors après si c'est de la
cueillette et qu'on congèle et ben
pourquoi pas c'est ça mais c'est pas
forcément des fraises du Chili c'est ce
que je voulais dire oui ah oui off quand
on en passe beaucoup dans la pâtisserie
mais effectivement dans dans quand on va
à la montagne vous avvez raison en tout
cas je trouve ça bien de de de penser à
une pâtisserie de saison aussiis merci
Emmanuel jry d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans politique àab merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi et puis on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
LCP